bernard faroux que c'est une magnifique
histoire d'amour entre un homme de
télévision et un beau labrador crème
depuis que je laissais vrai que c'est un
bonheur total et ce prénom il ne l'a pas
choisie par hasard c'était soit fernand
soiffards au bon c'était l'année des f
et en fait j'ai choisi faro c'était
assez élégant choffat rochus avait un
côté royal ça lui va bien pour lui cette
relation était très importante c'est de
l'engagement quotidien c'est très
important c'est aussi important que le
mariage
c'est simple les deux amis étaient
inséparables il faisait tout ensemble
petit déjeuner tour en bagnole est
ambato cheveux au vent balade sur la
plage à les battre à chaque session
terry sur le canapé restaurant en
tête-à-tête je ne vais que dans les
restaurants où on accepte les chiens
prostate en refermant chèvre au fait moi
aussi mais en général je pars en
gueulant s'étaient amassées rare et même
enregistrement sur les plateaux télé
voilà il se met dans la caméra carrément
mais malheureusement farooqi travers un
art pour le paradis des chiens à l'âge
de 14 ans très atteinte par cette
séparation ô combien douloureuse bernard
montiel n'a jamais osé bouger la gamelle
de farouk et n'a jamais repris à notre
chien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est touchant et plein d'émotion
c'était il ya quatorze ans qu'il est
parti et vous l'avez accompagné jusqu'à
la fin vraiment je suis désolé parce
qu'elle n'a qui peuvent pas comprendre
cette douleur qu'on peut avoir pour un
animal mais je lis beaucoup et même tous
les gens qui partagent leur vie avec un
animal vous comprennent alors le cadeau
qu'on voulait vous faire justement c'est
30 de rentrer en médiation avec sa route
parce que c'est possible grâce à aurélie
on peut commencer alors ouais je vais
tâcher de me concentrer à ce qui est du
monde et j'ai pas l'habitude des
plateaux camp des loges j'avoue on est
alors
alors je peux expliquer comment ça
fonctionne quand même tout à vous
agissiez comprendre alors en fait les
animaux me parle sous forme d'image que
je réceptionne
ça n'est pas forcément des dialogues
comme nous on parle des fois il ya des
images il ya des ressentis dans ma
poitrine ou je sens son émotion je sens
les douleurs physiques aussi ce sont que
des rangées des ressentis je peux avoir
des détails mais aussi de choses
personnelles à vous dire parce que les
animaux
après après avoir passé le voile parce
que là mais elle meurt pas elle continue
à aimer et à vous aimer bernard c'est
important de le savoir les animaux
restent prêts gouffre tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
donc voilà je vais vous dire ce que ce
que ce que j'ai je vais avoir des petits
détails je vous dira tout simplement
mais j'ai besoin de votre coopération
pour pouvoir comprendre parce que ça
c'est vous qui serez d'accord d'accord
alors il vous faut tôt 1 voilà alors oui
alors j'ai étudié un petit peu quand
même avant de venir parce que je dis au
cas où je stresse rai1 ici il faut quand
même que j'arrivais
alors j'ai retenu qu'en fait
farouche c'est un chien qui est là qui
est posée
alors je parle au présent d'accord parce
que moi je le sens là au présent je sens
que c'est un chien en fait qui est très
posé et quand il est là en fait il
investit les lieux alors tout autour de
vous
je les ai sentis
vraiment vraiment posé et quand je dis
ça c'est que autour de votre périmètre
autour de son périmètre il ya un
instinct qui est protecteur mais comme
si il était vraiment très très zen il
bouge que si a besoin c'est pas un chien
qui se baladait quand il était sur les
plateaux avec vous ils étaient vraiment
là j'ai vu aussi que de temps en temps
il ya des choses qui sentait et que
quand
il lève un petit peu là les la babine là
pour montrer qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne supporte pas mais il va pas ils
attaquent pas ils vont il n'y pas plus
que ça avec beaucoup beaucoup de respect
mais il fait sentir qu'il ya quelque
chose qui lui convient pas vous souvenez
de ce chien c'est bien de lui dont je
suis là non mais c'est bien lui dont je
vous parle pour reconnaissez série bien
sûr qu'en fait il a une prestance et
j'ai senti aussi que en fait ils aboient
peu mais c'est un gros où j'ai passé le
concours de chez d'aboiements de chiens
mais à force d'être très très peu mais
c'est pas c'est un aboiement qui est là
qui est fournier grave et c'est un seul
mais en fait hein c'est avec un chien
avec énormément de prestance alors
justement aurélie est ce que farouk a un
message pour bernard aujourd'hui alors
alors j'ai vu qu'il est régulièrement
dans la voiture il devait faire beaucoup
de voitures avec vous c'est à dire qu'il
était partout avec moi franchement la
voiture c'est vraiment l'endroit où il
est resté encore toujours avec vous il
aimait la voiture il aimait beaucoup la
voiture et il est assis derrière à
droite moi c'est là où je le vois
essentiellement wii ou à côté souvent on
met à droite
pourquoi pour est ce que les chiens
reste comme ça auprès de leurs maîtres
pourquoi est ce que l'âme d'un chien
reste c'est très important où est-ce
qu'au bout d'un moment il ya une coupure
et et l'âme par mais c'est l'amour c'est
l'amour tout simplement parce que l'âme
elle les fait que d'amour et l'amour des
animaux elle reste coûte que coûte parce
que il faut savoir et c'est très
important l'animal il sait pas aimer
l'humain a déjà du mal à savoir aimer à
savoir s'est mis lui même à savoir aimer
donc du coup aussi mais l'amour l'amour
des animaux c'est pas de l'amour c'est
de la dévotion c'est un ces conditions
les fusées ccc sacrifices et ils sont
d'ailleurs en ce moment dans ce
sacrifice entre guillemets pour nous
apprendre à nous aimer alors est ce
qu'aujourd'hui farouk il a vraiment un
message alors un message pour le futur
pour maintenant il reste à auprès de lui
alors le message bernard est bien c'est
qu'il faut s'occuper de guérir son coeur
de ce départ de son départ parce que en
fait à chaque fois
que vous êtes en douleur parce qu'il
n'est plus à côté de vous il a de la
peine ça lui fait de la peine parce que
c'est pas à lui qu'il pense mais avoue
la peine que vous avez vous il a du mal
à supporter alors si vous voulez on va
se revoir après je vous explique comment
faire
merci merci beaucoup
mais rien
savoir que ça fait 14 ans mais que vous
avez laissé la gamelle exactement au
même endroit oui j'ai rien touché j'ai
rien touché il a même son lit il ya tout
même s'il venait me rejoindre tous les
matins mais il a son deal à kamel dehors
j'ai rien toucher ce mandat émis
l'hypothèse où il est il est près de
vous et peut-être qu'un jour votre coeur
sera ouvert pour un pour un nouveau
vainqueur est très ouvert pour d'autres
animaux ça c'est évident ok merci
beaucoup et demi environ
[Applaudissements]